another day another failed attempt at
death if scp-682 had anything even
resembling a sense of humor he might ask
for it to be printed on a motivational
poster and stuck to the side of his
containment chamber where he eternally
melts and regrows at the mercy of high
concentration acid they just
cross-tested him with abel again
unlike some of the others he'd been
forced to face that tattooed swordsman
seemingly wasn't intelligent enough to
fear he'd always come back just as
stupid and violent this encounter had
left the heart to destroy reptile at 30
percent of his previous body mass bloody
and bashed he'd survived the encounter
he always survived they brought what was
left of him back to his cell in a
forklift a blasted forklift how could it
even be more humiliating as his eyes
started to grow back in his head he
could swear he even saw one of the
technicians laughing at him his name tag
read agent nigel kelly noted 682 would
specifically hunt down and kill him the
next time he breached of course every
single day he plotted revenge against
the human race along with everything
else but the sum they owed in pain blood
and despair could never be repaid in
full
after all every single one of them
except dr bright could only really die
once they'd brought 682 to the precipice
a thousand times only for his own body
to cheat him and deprive him of the
sweet release of death and if the
foundation had their way it would be
done a thousand times more and they
wouldn't even stop there 632 couldn't
even imagine the number of containment
breaches it would take to deal a blow
even comparable to the one he had faced
all he could do was dream dream of a
reckoning that would turn the tables
something that would plunge humanity
into the state of constant pain and
terror that had been all he'd ever known
since these fumbling sadists and white
coats had locked him up here what a
beautiful day that would be little did
scp-682 know that very day was about to
break miles and miles away from the
facility where scp-682 was kept after
all orders from the o5 council have hard
mandates on the minimum distances
between people and a site holding a
monster as volatile as 682 parents
watched their children laughing and
frolicking in an idyllic playground some
squealed with glee as they descended the
slide some of the more ambitious little
tykes tried to go over the bar on the
swings others waited in line for some
delicious soft serve at a parked ice
cream truck one mother brought an ice
cream cone and walked over to a nearby
bench where she began to enjoy her
delicious frozen treat it was a
remarkably hot day out and a little ice
cream was the perfect addition to her
relaxation while her kids were occupied
you could see the distant air wobbling
in the heat already her ice cream was
starting to melt white rivulets
dribbling down the sides of the cone and
onto her hands suddenly almost
imperceptibly the quality of the light
shifted the kind of thing you'd dismiss
as a trick of the eyes and forget just
as quickly were it not for the
catastrophic effects that were about to
unfold as the woman leaned forward to
lick her melting ice cream something
dripped onto her skirt but as she looked
down she slowly realized that what
dripped onto her wasn't the pure white
of her ice cream it was the same exact
tone as her skin she felt a terrible
burning sensation all through her body
the most horrible debilitating pain
she'd ever experienced like every cell
in her body was screaming and trying to
make a break for it she turned to the
other parents sitting near the
playground they were screaming too
each collapsed to the ground with
agonizing slowness different parts of
their body falling at different speeds
as they transition through states of
matter when they hit the ground they
were taking on a liquid state screaming
worthless boneless blobs the woman even
saw her own arm wilting like a
time-lapse video of a dying flower she
dripped and sluiced through the cracks
in the bench until nothing recognizably
human was left only a soggy ice cream
cone sitting uneaten in an instant
billions of screams rang out over planet
earth day
had broken
things would never ever be the same
again as almost half of humanity
instantaneously
took on a liquid state needless to say
with the most dangerous and far-reaching
anomalous incident in human history
suddenly breaking out without any kind
of warning the scp foundation was
incredibly busy this would take some
unprecedented action the members of the
o5 council who weren't melted during the
initial blast convened over secure video
link while sequestering themselves
underground and what amounted to
multiple human lifetimes of some of the
most high pressure choices imaginable
they made the most difficult decision
since the very beginning of the scp
foundation in the service of all mankind
they would now break the masquerade the
scp foundation would at long last step
out of the shadows to save the rest of
humanity from the tyranny of the light
broadcasts went out all over the globe
every tv screen every live stream every
radio broadcast was commandeered they
gave instructions based on the scattered
intel they had for some reason the sun
had turned against them exposure would
lead any biological creatures melting
away into sentient piles of
flesh-colored sludge people would remain
indoors and away from any light sources
all windows must remain covered travel
only at night and even then heavily
covered with protective gear there can
only be one objective for whoever is
left make your way to the nearest scp
foundation containment facility and seek
refuge inside if anyone could figure out
the answer to this terrifying
existential riddle it would be the scp
foundation anyone who is exposed should
be considered lost while as always the
scp foundation did all they could to
project a sense of control over the
situation on the inside it was
pandemonium somehow despite everything
this event had taken all of them by
surprise how could anyone have predicted
that the cradle of our solar system's
delicate living balance would suddenly
become a meat grinder a huge number of
foundation operatives were wiped out in
the initial exposure global
communication infrastructure had been
devastated it was pure chaos and to
scp-682
as another evil tactician once put it
chaos was a ladder from the inside of
his acid tank 682 could sense the fear
and pain suddenly exuding from his
surrounding environment it was greater
than ever before what was happening out
there this was no average containment
breach something was really really
happening out there 682 began to adapt
and finally attune its hearing until
could pick up the chatter from outside
uh maybe we can convert some of the
d-class barracks into serviceable
bunkers for the refugees it's not like
we're prepared for this kind of capacity
oh god oh god we've lost sight seven
site 10 site 23 site 40 site 52 ah death
toll looks to be in the billions well we
don't know if they're dead technically
but they're sure as hell not human
anymore now this is the big one this is
it xk class even 2 000 is unaccounted
for is all five crazy that they think
we're fighting the freaking sun needless
to say 682's curiosity was peaked
anything that could light a fire under
the foundation like this was something
he could enjoy
and with his impressively strategic
intellect he intuited that a time of
great strife for the foundation would be
the perfect time to breach containment
because whenever there's violence fear
and chaos on a mass scale
scp-682 will be there causing it 682
began adapting his pores and endocrine
system to begin releasing a powerful
alkaline substance little by little the
alkaline neutralized the acids
surrounding him turning it into little
more than plain water he then converted
his internal systems to have extreme
endothermic rather than exothermic
properties causing his surrounding
temperature to drop rapidly until all
the water in the tank completely froze
around him the ice expanded beyond the
limit of the containment unit busting
the rivets of the metal frame and
shattering the reinforced glass with
this goal achieved 682 raised his
internal temperatures to incredible
highs melting the ice around him once
again he was free and ready for some
good old-fashioned carnage and mayhem
perhaps he could get a better handle on
this strange new situation too it was
all rather exciting just a girl with
goals huh scp foundation personnel were
already running around like ants trying
desperately to avoid the caustic laser
beam of the magnifying glass you can
only imagine how much worse it made
matters when 682 suddenly burst through
the wall kool-aid man's style he began
to ruthlessly massacre everyone around
him just one of those days you know the
typical order during a 682 containment
breach is to dispatch all available
units to get him back under control the
issue with this particular containment
breach was that given the human
population was very rapidly being melted
and they were the only ones who could
potentially save the rest they didn't
really have any available units to
pursue and recontain 682 for once he
really wasn't a priority and that meant
terrible things for whoever he ran into
682 slaughtered his way through any
researchers or guards who dared to get
in his way disgusting creatures really
better off dead he clawed and bit and
tore and crushed with almost childlike
glee leaving great piles of bodies in
his wake all the while he was pondering
the things he heard those foundation
drones saying something about the sun
and an xk class scenario hmm interesting
682 also observed that any apertures
that could potentially allow light into
the facility had also been shuttered
perhaps they weren't overreacting this
time like they always did with him maybe
they were dealing with some kind of
phenomenon that would now cast this
wretched world and those who lived in it
into the void wouldn't that be a fitting
karmic fate for them all still 682's
bloodlust didn't outweigh his logic he
needed to know more about the situation
before proceeding and in this
maybe he could kill two foundation birds
with one stone elsewhere in the building
alarms blared the air was suffused with
panicked voices and frequent screams
nobody knew what was going on not really
they'd only gotten details here and
there and the details they'd received
were terrifying all their families and
loved ones outside probably gone so many
of the people in so much of the world
they'd been fighting for risking it all
for had disappeared in an instant
carried to hell on a ray of sunshine why
were they still here was this horror not
truly uncontainable these questions were
swimming through the mind of agent nigel
kelly as he stood alone in his office
almost catatonic he'd had his friends
and family on the outside all likely
reduced to those horrible fleshy blobs
he was alone in the world risking his
life for nothing how could this get any
worse his mind kept repeating that
question again and again and again and
the universe gave him an answer in the
form of a deep reptilian voice saying
into his ear from behind he turned with
a shriek to see the terrible eyes of 682
staring into his own before he could try
to flee a reach for a weapon that he
knew would only mildly annoy the already
furious beast 682 reached out with a
massive clawed hand and grabbed him by
the torso lifting him up into the air
the creature was gripping so tight that
he could feel his ribs starting to crack
the monster hissed
do i seem like the time to tell jokes
do you feel
like laughing now
agent kelly begged and pleaded for his
life fighting for his next breath from
the crushing squeeze of the creature's
terrible hand 682 roared at him to be
silent and ordered him to tell him
everything he knew about the situation
going on outside if the information was
useful 682 might show his thought to be
non-existent magnanimous side and let
agent kelly live of course agent kelly
didn't fancy his chances but what other
choice did he have he told 682 that the
higher-ups were calling this
scp-001 when day breaks the sun had gone
rogue somehow and being in contact with
any kind of sunlight would now cause
people to instantaneously melt into
horrifying living sludge and it wasn't
just people the condition also affected
anomalies and interestingly it appeared
to negate all previous anomalous effects
so 682's adaptational ability may not
even save it if it was exposed he told
682 everything he knew are you are you
gonna let me live agent kelly asked
struggling to breathe 682's terrible maw
twisted into what might have been a
smile
he said with unsettling joy
[Music]
a terrible scream emanated from the
agent's office if one good thing could
be said for what happened to agent kelly
that day at least he didn't live long
enough to see the ravages of the
terrible sun first hand 682 began to
formulate a plan he took agent kelly's
wristwatch and integrated it into his
body so he'd have a permanent internal
clock it was the middle of summer so the
sun would have reliably set at 9 00 pm
and would likely begin its rise around
5am it would be relatively easy to avoid
the sun all things considered for lack
of a more eloquent way to put it when it
comes to adapting to new threats scp-682
is simply built different after
slaughtering a few other members of scp
foundation staff for the road hey it's
not like anyone was fit to stop him 682
began enacting the new phase of his plan
his body grew a thick smooth carapace
and his front set of limbs began to grow
his muscles bulging and his claws
growing the tips turning into sharp flat
scoops with sudden and tremendous force
682 began boring his way into the ground
tunneling clawing through concrete and
dirt with absolute ease normally the scp
foundation would have deployed high-tech
seismic sensors and the kind of tunnel
boring machines that elon musk could
only dream of to intercept and recapture
him but during the endless horrors of
the breaking day he had carte blanche to
escape and live it up in the ruins of
this rapidly dying world eventually 682
had bored his way into a roomy sewer
pipe the perfect place to wait out a few
hours up above so many millions screamed
either in fear or in agony there had
been some new developments that the scp
foundation had been yet to account for
while they knew that those melted by the
rogue son were technically alive and
trapped in a permanent state of
suffering what the foundation didn't
know was that these former humans were
incredibly dangerous in their own right
the sun hadn't just irreparably warped
their bodies it had also irreparably
warped their minds it has enslaved them
made them zealots acolytes they
developed the instinct to coagulate into
giant fleshing masses driven by the
single-minded purpose of finding victims
and dragging them into the light where
they too could be converted into these
terrible fleshy creatures and add to the
masses they were the rogue sons boots on
the ground metaphorically speaking and
now they were the foundation's greatest
challenge in getting a handle on this
situation again before it was just
encouraging people to avoid the sun
now the sun was actively trying to
increase its exposure but 682 who was
having a relaxing evening not being
melted for once down in the sewers
couldn't care less he was having the
most calming few hours he'd had in years
he waited checking the time making sure
that it would be dark before he began
tunneling back up to the surface world
he surfaced in the middle of the city
miles away from the foundation facility
he'd spent so many decades being
tortured in he tasted the cool night air
and observed the desolation that had
been wrought all around him buildings
were on fire cars were crashed and
overturned the ground was cracked
garbled scp foundation public service
announcements played to nobody in the
broken display windows of electronics
stores giant wads of human flesh roamed
slithering around searching for new
victims one noticed 682 and began to
approach him jibbering madly in a chorus
of strange voices the hard to destroy
reptile wasted no time in attacking it
tore apart most of the hideous blob and
began hungrily devouring the chunks the
form may have been different but it
still tasted like human flesh and
scp-682
savored every bite it would be
so simple these blobs of idiotic flesh
were so easy to kill and there would be
so many terrified humans in this
devastated world hiding away in dark
places holding out the hope that maybe
they could reach the safety of a
foundation facility 682 chuckled at the
very thought foolish hope would drown in
an endless well of black caustic despair
he
would find them he would rest
underground in the day and then hunt
them in the dark they would all die
screaming
bloodying his claws and fangs
nothing
and nobody would stop him he looked out
over the strange new world and laughed a
little louder
[Music]
it was just
delightful now go check out
scp-682 waze scp foundation try to kill
hard to destroy reptile and scp-682
craziest mutations and adaptations for
more exploits from the lizard who just
won't die